almost everyone on the studio team has a
development background so we're all very
familiar with the love-hate relationship
you filled up with the tools you use and
that's why we started building studio
because we wanted it to be as easy as
possible to ship Android apps
but of course I'm saying this because
I'm on the team so instead of listening
to me we asked a bunch of Android
developers why they choose to use studio
the reason our team at Strava uses
Android studio is because it's built for
Android the new emulator feels like
using a phone but it's on your computer
for a long time what we were doing is we
were deploying to our phone in our hand
then like looking up at the screen
looking down it's even faster to just
look next to your IDE and see it on your
screen getting the latest from Google is
kind of like sitting outside of their
office and asking for an update but a
little easier I'm member of the Android
team in Netflix and we are using the
Android studio as best way to develop
networks app on Android you don't really
think about core checks until you need
them right so for example you were
trying to look up the thing and you pass
integer value to it that's example and
understood your core track would
actually find potential problem that you
will have and your studio helps me
remember where I came from and where I
want to go
it keeps me the flow so I can code
faster I used a lot of the little
shortcuts like find usages or go to
whatever classes extend the current
class the navigation that I used on it
keeps a sort of replica of my trail of
thoughts all of these shortcuts help me
fly through the code and at Hipmunk we
love to fly all of the professional
Android developers we talked to use
Android studio for their apps and their
feedback has been really important for
us to know to focus on things like speed
smarts and platform support
our hope is that this lets them spend
their time concentrating on building
amazing experiences for their end-users
I don't understand like why this video
exists it's like Android studio it's
really good it's like what else you
gonna use